hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay I fixed all the
audio problems I double-checked
everything everything should be working
phenomenally so no problems from here on
out and um I had to actually get back to
this point I had to redo it all because
I saved wasn't in the right place but
either way everything's fixed now
Lydia's still in her [ __ ] outfit which
is awesome for a distraction and another
change that I'm gonna make because the
Skyrim let's play is gonna be so long I
don't want to do two episodes a day for
this at any time so I'm gonna make each
Skyrim episode 30 minutes long now every
episode of Skyrim is gonna be thirty
minutes long and it's gonna be every day
but no more than once a day and that
leaves room for other stuff like my
amnesia stuff and other stuff like that
afraid of monsters cry for your custom
stories anyway so getting back into it
gotta find a distraction Lydia flash
them please please Lydia please come on
do it for me please
it'll be okay I do call seeing you we
have a relation I can't talk about the
politics and yeah that's nice I don't
care can you distract someone to me can
you flash these people I don't know I'm
not sure none of these guys a wit about
the religious huh what brings you
fortunately I am here to remind you're
useless to me lady talk to me spoken and
words unfair faces and fine behold are
whip that are our word for this reason I
avoid them whatever you Siskin Ellen was
mentality of the foul more embassy you
might distract check out these backs you
Ellen when always throws quite apartment
must be nude I feel I try to do my
little
as for long you're all useless to meet
you what are you doing here
if there's anything I can ever do for
you do not ah here we go
I can begin to repay your generosity is
that all stand back I will behold come
on Lydia yeah the man's way you've got
to work okay that's it
really let's go let's go okay fine not
as rambunctious and awesome as I had
hoped it would be but whatever fine
gimme Oh mine that you said you were out
of all til one you liar I'll take all
this mine mine okay let's go what are we
doing what are we doing here piling up
in the hallway come on no time for this
huh shut up get moving
Lydia I swear let's hope nobody saw a
slip out
okay that's fantast back to the kitchen
your gear is hidden in the larder all
right just stay close and let me do any
talking got it okay follow me you got it
look lead the way
fine I'll lead the way
hello baby yes yeah okay gichan's I mean
I'm not one to talk I'm an Argonian but
look at me I'm so handsome anyway I
didn't realize that eating sugar was
permitted uh-huh yeah you saw nothing
except my handsome here's a chest with
all my white or behind you don't screw
this up you shut up all three now you up
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
I actually was smart enough when I went
back to give myself the healing potions
this time okay let there you stay just
the way you are you're perfect that way
but me I need my stuff
oh yeah much better much better I felt
naked without alright itself being what
don't think Wyatt Cobain see how
stealthy I am Elvin light-armored Wow
holy crap that is light oh no you don't
a little fire doesn't hurt me sorry
Lydia so you got in the way
sorry Lydia you got in the way
stop getting in my way I need this elven
gear whoa someone there whoop adieu
watch out Lydia Oh perfect excellent
yeah not great but good enough all right
now gourd and garlic a gold um not much
here I'll take that control skill I
think oh nothing okay sorry Lydia you
fine don't be complaining are you fine
this openness Skyrim that's not the
right way all right come on get Lydia I
swear I know you're trying to throw
yourself at me but really now it's not
the time okay
Lydia I know I'm irresistible
please I I know this I've had to suffer
my whole life with this affliction of
how good I look but please
we're on a mission let's see a mission
to steal everything ooh those are big
potions ah vigorous ultimate I like
those words those are words I know all
right
that's it oh there's some food I'll take
that and grilled leeks I'll take that
play too who pushing regeneration most
dairy generations are everywhere I've
seen ya knocked your [ __ ] what do you
think of me now I've seen them
everywhere do only 13 here's another one
pushing regeneration I swear they're
everywhere whatever stuff in here I'll
take your flowers what you think of me
now
Skyrim again what how am I going the
right way I have no idea I either way
whatever let's go I'm outside now
oh hello yeah thanks need to talk with
you
Oh didn't hurt doesn't hurt that's the
best I can do douche yeah yeah hold on
I'm gonna fight you the second I just
need to take care of some looting oh
it's what you get for not wearing armor
yep yep yep mine mine
fine shut up Lydia stop it
Lydia I critted you where do you get out
of the way there we go my killing blow
my kill my kill Lydia I'm sorry did I
hurt you baby did I hurt you baby I'm
sorry I don't mean ooh don't run away
from me I'm sorry
you okay Lydia you're not looking so
good I mean you look fine I'm not saying
you're ugly or anything but you're
healthy kind of okay you're fine you're
fine it'll kill who Lydia come on we're
going inside now mine good hello I
didn't hurt dinner were you just a
serving guy oops hello
yeah the donor Oh she'll hahaha that did
you lots of stuff
are you a named real une ruelle in dil
Lydia
are you okay you okay Lydia you all
right you okay how you look fine all
right you're tough you're tough altar
wine another potion to regeneration oh
that's in here
some more dossier okay found that lots
of books don't care who cares about
books anyway let's say one of those
skill books by in pry not too many books
I'm not gonna hunt them all is that
another another potion of regeneration
why are there so many of those are they
even that good I have no idea here yep
some goodies um is that another another
potion regeneration I swear they're
everywhere let it please please I know
there's a bed right here but please keep
it in your pants we're on a mission
maybe later
of course you didn't want to sleep with
me that one time god I remember another
potion of regeneration I swear all right
that looks about it where am I going
anyway death Bell okay Lydia okay I
thought you were gonna throw yourself at
me again it's where it's cursed people
when it's my charms I judge people I
it's it's an annoying at some point
haggling glow dust lots of stuff all
right whatever
ooh what's in here ah I'm out of lock
picks I don't have any locks pick who's
me huh
damn it I should be able to smash it Oh
what's down here garlic garlic give me a
kidney keep you giving you garlic more
garlic and a gold record and a tundra a
neutral skull good MA all right now is
that another oh no that was a push a
minor healing
who's dead
hello somebody there where'd you come
from
I didn't hit you Lydia or I didn't mean
to Wang you regret your decision now
sorry Lydia I'm sorry you okay baby
sorry I'm sorry
where's I'm Melvin that's high value
that's high value what oh that's our
dude
hello dude hey how's it going yes Tian
Ranas don't know anything else about it
oh don't you I'd like to hear it all
whatever you want there's that yes he
matches the description as burn that's
all I know
okay okay what who no time to explain
okay okay yeah sure way I've seen the
guards use it to get rid of bodies it
must lead you go ahead as you know what
you're doing I've got to find a way what
Lydia please not now it's it's not the
time please please just give me some
space
oh hello what never mind yep
yabba-doo it Wow whose boots there we go
one down now
like I need a potion of regenerate or
actually I need to level up dad will do
it and what can I do
can I have the armor freaka frak I'll
just save the porn all of it sorry mal
born did I hit you there oh look at all
this elven armor it's not heavy armor so
I'm a terrible oh oh gone
I just I'll step in take all the credit
another elephant maze okay now they're
dead they messed with the wrong guy oh
hello oh you need me to get that for you
it's okay I understand everyone needs me
for something
hey where we going at the end
oh it's troll let's troll booth damn it
my Foose is down don't do it man [ __ ] Oh
hiss kit
block oh [ __ ] this guy still hurts like
a son-of-a-bitch
oh go away potion regen - godly a lot of
people have been suggesting that I
changed my UI but I actually don't mind
the UIL
[ __ ] oh man I got these health potions
ah right in your gullet down
you hurt Lydia how could you that's it
what a troll win purse unusual gem I've
gotten the unusual gem before but I
didn't get it here wait what now this
conjurer
Lydia you alright baby you all right you
all right you okay you okay good come on
I'll lead you out of the cave Gideon
knows I love her I mean doing sometimes
what she's our she's AI she can hold her
own in a fight just not against a troll
mal born where are you going now
now born not now born Matt but oh hey
you you didn't have to help me
so thanks I'd screw you I mean you're
welcome
you didn't have to help my guy so I
guess I'm done here thanks umm what
what's out there
castle defense must be some mod I've
never seen that before
all right going back to Riverwood like I
said before new episodes are gonna be 30
minute long 30 minutes long what could
it mean hey it's me I think the
blacksmith came over to fight me what do
you want fain dog thinks he can move big
bang dog this guy needs to shut up about
Fame Dahl had it up to here with feigned
all right come on give me my reward
anyway drink to cook that's phenomenal
you made it out alive I could tell less
your gear safe in my room as promised
oh is it what oh really
that seems hard to believe eze burn
figure the thumb what would be honest I
don't know who died bar trying to find
out that burn on you mean aside from
wanting to kill every blue s burn was
one of the blades archivists back before
the Thalmor smashed us during the Great
War
uh-huh he knew everything about the
ancient dragon lore of the blaze Oh
obsessed with it real nobody paid much
attention back then okay that's fine I
guess he wasn't as creeped Rifton a
you'd better get to Rifton talk - brynee
off Britany off he's well-connected a
good start
oh no and when you find Esbern if you
think I'm paranoid you just ask him
where he was on the 30th of Frost of all
xxx up frostfall you'll know what it
means February
okay all right that's fine I got these
dossiers did you take them Dolphy a
thumb or Delsea you go okay I'm not
reading all that if you wanna read it
just pause it where I flip the pages no
not I swear oh my god you got to be
kidding me
click not Ulfric I want to click on the
S burn one there we go maybe I should
change the UI godly okay that's a lot of
crap Rifton I must have automatic reread
him or something okay what have you got
in here what's that orcish great sword
hell yeah the blade sword oh yeah
there's a lot of good gear in here
how are did I just miss miss those I
swear those weren't there before
that's crazy awesome oh it's all my
stuff gimme gimme gimme
I got it take all caring too much screwy
you're caring too much uh-oh
so heavy Lydia come here Lydia Lydia
yeah I need to give you your gear back
anyways yeah you read by maybe what do
you want me to carry Oh give her her
maybe I should give her the Elven armor
I may have got enough sets but I know
that wouldn't drop my weight I need to
give her actual arm
what no okay give her the cuff food
steel armor gauntlets shield and I still
have too much weight you carry the you
carry the damage damage twelve that's
not much you carry that you carry these
elven maces I'm gonna keep that that is
nice
actually it's not that nice actually
it's not much better it's no better than
mine I mean it's not sharpened or
anything but I'm alright
you carry that it's still carrying too
much where why do I myself why about so
much wine
I swear what is what is weighing me down
here flute
okay take that goblet screw that why do
I have a goblet lantern no that's that
Lantern you were all talking about
where's all this weight coming from
space core thumb our boots no seriously
I don't know where all this weight is
coming from key took that I guess I
guess take all of these that's you Dale
yeah that did it
okay that's doing it okay now oh don't
put it on your back so weird Lydia your
quirky quirky gotta take all of them
back like it I can fit all them okay
Jace Lydia
yeah what is wrong with you ah okay all
right now what was I doing
do you need something no not from you
what was I doing I was going to Rifton
Ripton that's where I need to go which
means it's down there which means I need
to go to the Whiterun stables to be able
to go to Rifton den to Dunnan don't no
no none dahhh no dahhh dahhh no no non
hey yeah how's it going need a ride
yes where do you want to go what else
what I need Rifton please sure thing
buddy man that was the most evil
transaction of it all shut up oh shut up
I don't care why would they even have
that dialog if it was just gonna cut off
in the middle of it that's annoying
alright Rifton here we go Oh horsies
connect too lazy to walk eh well you
found the right Oh fu hello her before I
let you into rhythm you need to pay to
this hole I remember this for the
privilege of entering the Saha what does
it matter
oh I kill thieves I think you'd be a
little smart all you might what what I
kill thieves think you'd be a little
smarter than that
what right keep your voice down I
persuade them but my big gigantic
muscles don't let you win whatever let
me unlock the gate whatever god that was
stupid
yours oh I should just murder you anyway
whatever I'm angry about that I'm not
strong enough apparently
come on I got things to do
they've got Rifton discovered don't care
I don't know why trouble
what what's it to you I'm not scared of
you use those lost that you have ready
there's need around here the black
briars have ripped me I'm all i watch
the streets for him if you need dirt on
anything I'm your guy but it'll cost you
oh I would kick the [ __ ] out of you
longer mall I would beat the crap out of
you oh I'm really getting tired of your
excuses when you borrowed don't care
don't care about your stupid problems
who are you
no yeah you that's who's working your
life for all that coiny accounting hey
lad Oh what Oh besides he look like your
pockets are a little light on coin ah
passing on a golden opportunity as well
I've got a bit of a bar in my line of
work you know what extra sinner Oh
whatever calls a distraction once you
have it I want you to please not a
sneaky Argonian noticing sorry
never mind in Lagos if you change your
mind I'll find your stupidness glad to
see you finally came to your sense of oh
I want you to there's someone
no come on come on tell me when you're
ready I'm ready wait until I stop it
just I hope you're describing better
than the other ones he spends too much
time worrying about rifted I thought
those were health potions I have
something amazing to show you that
demands your attention well then
everyone comes running to hear this that
sons thank you hey Argonian buddy how's
it going you look like a pansy what am i
doing
well this way everyone over here what
Lydia get out of the nice Oregonians way
what is it this time patience Blanche a
what am i doing I'm stealing a ring or
something about the whiz Behcet's wait
wait hang on hang on hang on aah
oh my goodness oh-oh-oh steal my dezzy's
ring that one's water Oh in here you
can't see me I'm hidden totally totally
him yeah totally
damn it told you I'm not sneaky there we
go you can't see me you can't see me
what again area okay so I'm stealing my
Desi's silver ring planting okay I'm
totally awesome at this game and whatnot
no one's seen them in years
sneaky pinky can't see me protection but
I can promise you that you can't see me
there save and then put it in
give huh what a waste of time all right
I did your stupid task looks like I
travelers done it with the sword but I
did it and here you go the way things
have been going around here yeah but
never mind that
you did the job and you did it well
first of all there's more where that
came from
no way it was wrong the group I
represent when you come to your senses
okay that's nice now about the old guy
yeah I bet I know your guy he's hiding
out in the rat wave Warren's paying us
good coin for nobody to know about it
okay if I have to hold your hand that's
under your feet lad just follow the the
walls have ears all right fine fine fine
fine
down here okay all right fine des burn
in the right way wards that's what I'm I
do get out of my way stupid so stow bed
ah people always getting in my way just
a fact of life
who wants them huh nope ah
got ya [ __ ] you go take care of that
guy Lydia thanks baby
yeah oh I didn't sell my [ __ ] ah
oh girl alright get rid of that I can't
pick up anything else apparently I
should drop that I've got it's worth too
much all right fine let's not think of
it Wow Lydia yeah y'all stop messing
around with them and just kill them
straight up all right ah what I'm
carrying too much to run I just picked
up a freaking gem where did I get where
did I pick up wait
oh my god I'm gonna go I gotta get rid
of these they aren't worth anything
anyone get out here here whoa Lydia hold
on wait what are you what are you using
oh you're using the Orcas sword oh good
for you good for you you're learning ah
I thought you were using a shield just
two seconds ago
don't know what happen to that okay oh
wow I saw that before I saw that all
right then what Oh schemer found you
gianna walk using your fists oh this is
the guy this is the guy oh this is the
guy that had the gloves of the buda list
from that video how to be a badass in
Skyrim
well what Oh miss me dick
don't matter I could even going the
right way I don't even know was that
another trap didn't bother me is that
iron battle-ax out butterfly down here
what who are you dad that's what you are
wonk wonk Triplett here oh man
lethal combo these guys don't know
what's up okay this way wait this can't
be right find Esbern yep this that's it
EEE EEE hello who's out here
oh okay Randolph I don't care you don't
need to talk to you I need to talk to
you I'm not different well I'm different
from you and that I'm totally better and
more handsome what was that oh hello
cowboy get ready to die withers Wang ha
ha ha
ridiculous you think you can fight me
yes
whomp see Lydia
you just kill them you just run up to
them and then you kill them easiest
thing in the world
oh man I basically can't pick up any
more gear but it don't matter
oh hey Lydia that you're doing good on
running up to the enemies but seriously
just okay
Lydia watch walk right up their legs and
then slide them down their neck couldn't
be simpler Lydia could not be simpler
you got it you okay oh it's okay I'm not
criticizing you beautiful oh you are
anyway that's all the time I got for
this hope you enjoyed the new 30 minute
episodes while I do this until I get to
the end this way I can basically get
through Skyrim quicker without getting
in the way of the other videos I think
this is gonna work out best for everyone
and thanks again for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye-bye